estos residentes rusos se apresuran a
cruzar la frontera con Finlandia son de
los pocos miles y Afortunados que lo
hicieron a tiempo a partir de la
medianoche del jueves los rusos con una
visa de turista válida para la zona
schengen ya no pueden entrar a este país
de la Unión Europea no
alcancía a cruzar no sé cómo lo harán
los demás es triste triste es una pena
que los finlandeses ya no nos admitan
qué podemos hacer
desde que Vladimir Putin anunció una
masiva movilización de tropas los
ingresos en suelo finlandés se han
duplicado la cantidad de los que
cruzaban diariamente la frontera ha
rondado las 7-8000 personas los últimos
días Por supuesto estoy contra el cierre
de fronteras porque Finlandia es el país
europeo más cercano a nosotros ahora
mucha gente sensata que está consciente
de la situación no tendrá la oportunidad
de huir de este mordor
la decisión del gobierno finlandés
coincide con el anuncio de Rusia de la
anexión de cuatro regiones ucranianas
que la Unión Europea considera ilegal y
también se dan respuesta al supuesto
Sabotaje del gasoducto nordstream en el
mar Báltico el propósito de estas
medidas es parar por completo el turismo
ruso en Finlandia y el tránsito hacia
otros países a través de Finlandia
nuestro gobierno ha evaluado que hay una
amenaza a las relaciones internacionales
del país
desde que comenzó la guerra Finlandia ha
estado cada vez más incómoda con la
llegada de rusos a su país la decisión
de helsinki después de la sepolonia y
los tres estados bálticos este mes lo
que convierte Finlandia en el último de
los cuatro países de la Unión Europea
limítrofes con Rusia en cerrar sus
fronteras a los rusos con visas de
turistas